There are a couple of different solutions for this,
but all of these solutions will have in common that you need at least
4 monitoring devices to monitor the whole network,
and I will show you one of these solutions.
So you could install one here, which would monitor these cables here.
You could install one here to monitor these cables,
and then you need one here, or you could have one here.
There are other possibilities, as I said, to monitor these 2 cables here.
And then finally, you can install one here to monitor these 2.
So this is one solution where you use 4 monitoring devices
to monitor the whole network, and it's not possible with 3.